this video is sponsored by brilliant
start learning for free with a link in
the description and the first 200 get
20% off the annual Premium Subscription
April 11th 2020 was as much as one can
be at the moment a day like any other
as the us past half a million cases of
coronavirus no one paid much attention
to the unremarkable news in North Korea
the state-run Korean Central News Agency
published a relatively mundane story
about Kim jong-un attending a Workers
Party meeting where this photo was taken
what no one knew is that this would be
the last appearance by the Supreme
Leader for almost three weeks after
missing his grandfather's birthday
celebration on Wednesday something he
had never done in his nine years in
power it became clear something was up
and the rumors began on Monday the South
Korean websites Daily NK reported that
hoon was recovering from a
cardiovascular operation quoting
anonymous sources then CNN ran the
headline us source North Korean leader
in grave danger after surgery
turning the regional report into a
global story soon an MSNBC anchor with
700,000 followers tweeted the news and a
media executive posted to candles on her
way Bowl page adding more fuel to the
fire an old picture of Kim Jong Il's
body photoshopped with the face of his
son began circulating online along with
the video of Chinese military vehicles
supposedly rushing to the border which
was later identified as being filmed
further south and jung-soo a South
Korean lawmaker one of only two born in
the North gave his death and 99%
probability US Senator Lindsey Graham
said he would be quote shocked if he's
not dead or in some incapacitated State
and one of the South's three major
newspapers published an article formally
announcing the death and if one needed
any further confirmation routers
reported Beijing had dispatched a team
of medical experts to advise on the
situation during this time the South's
National Intelligence Service repeatedly
denied anything unusual was going on
as panic turned to confusion and
confusion turned to skepticism the
original Daily NK story issued a
correction it was actually based only on
a single unnamed source CNN changed its
headline to sound more cautious and the
previously mentioned tweet and post were
deleted for a week or so the media
boldly asserted he's either dead or
alive then on May 1st 20 days after his
last appearance Kim jong-eun returned
this time to inspect a fertilizer
factory outside Pyongyang in hindsight
it's no secret how these rumors spread
he had a procedure became he's in
critical condition after surgery became
he's dead through a series of sloppy
journalistic escalations because so many
outlets published the story people
thought there must be some truth to it
after all this is perhaps the easiest
rumor to sell who would doubt 5 foot 7
300-pound a chain-smoking kim jong hoon
the man who had a harder time planting a
tree in his 30s than his 65 year old
South Korean counterpart would have
health troubles of course nothing that
happened on May 1st or since precludes
the possibility of Kim having surgery
some medical experts argue a new small
mark seen on the leaders right wrist
could be a sign of a cardiovascular
procedure he was also seen using a golf
cart as he did after a six-week absence
in 2014
caused by a suspected ankle injury
although he has used the cart at other
times as well another theory suggests
Kim may have been hiding from an
outbreak of coronavirus pyongyang
residents have reportedly been rushing
to stock up at grocery stores
confounding the problem is the current
lack of foreigners in the country and
minimal travel across the Chinese border
making reliable sources difficult to
find we may never know why Kim jong-eun
disappeared what we do know is that the
North Korean government chose not to
report on or snap a photo of their
leaders whereabouts to
those three weeks whatever the cause of
the disappearance the strategic reason
for silence is simple after the world
finishes celebrating the death of a
brutal murderous dictator it realizes
the somehow even scarier potential
alternative the subsequent chaotic
struggle for control of its nuclear and
chemical weapons rumors of Kim's death
are an accidental reminder of how bad
things could be and how much stability
is worth so while recent events may have
only been a false alarm they invite a
very real question one day possibly any
day Kim Jong moon will die or be
replaced and when that happens who will
inherit the nuclear codes in its 71
years of existence only three people and
one family have ever ruled the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
from the country's founding in 1948 kim
ill sung would stay in power for another
46 years until his death in 94 during
this time japan cycle through 21 prime
ministers britain xi and the u.s. nine
presidents the small Hermit Kingdom
would both outlive its Soviet Ally and
survive Chinese reform around the age of
60 the country's founder and then only
leader began planning his legacy first
considering his brother before deciding
on his son the North Korean dictionary
quietly changed its definition of
hereditary succession as a reactionary
custom of exploitative societies and
began distributing paintings depicting
the leader in a more loving fatherly
light for the next few decades the
favored eldest son Kim Jong Il began
climbing the party's ranks eventually
pronounced supreme commander of the
Korean People's Army in 1991 thanks to
this preparation when a heart attack
killed Kim il-sung in 1994 power was
smoothly inherited by his son becoming
the first hereditary transfer of power
in a communist country the question of
who would follow Kim jong-il was far
more complicated he first married on his
father's request in 1966 and had a
daughter two years later one year after
that they divorced and Kim
almost immediately and in secret found a
second woman with whom he had a son Kim
jong-nam three years later not knowing
of this second relationship or child Kim
jong-il's father instructed him to
remarry another woman he did and
together the couple had two daughters
finally a few years later he met a young
dancer with whom he had a daughter
yo-jong and two sons gyeong-cheol and
Jang hoon Kim jong-il kept each family
in separate walden residences in
pyongyang giving the children quiet and
very isolated lives where they would not
encounter each other when it came time
for boarding school Jeong Nam was sent
to Geneva while the youngest three went
to Bern what happened next is somewhat
disputed conventional wisdom says that
Kim jong-nam
as the eldest son was his father's
favorite and next in line for the throne
until May 2001 when he was caught
sneaking into Japan to visit Tokyo
Disney with a fake Dominican Republic
passport and Chinese name in truth the
Tokyo incident was likely just one more
straw on the camel's back
reinforcing what was already becoming
true in fact some doubt Disney was the
real reason for the trip or even
suggests the arrest was set up while Kim
Jong yams mother visited Pyongyang only
occasionally from her home in Moscow and
was said not to be particularly
ambitious Kim Jong Un's mother was
highly involved in political life
pushing behind the scenes for her son's
ascent to power seeing his side of the
family had lost favor the eldest son
lived an aimless life of parties in
Pyongyang until his father offered him a
deal get married and have a child and
you can leave North Korea which Kim
jong-nam
took moving with his family to Macau the
middle child meanwhile was considered
too quiet and unmotivated leaving only
the youngest kim jeong-hoon to be clear
was not the perfect candidate his mother
was born in Japan never legally married
to Kim jong-il and her sister had
defected still thanks to his mother's
maneuvering hoon was officially chosen
as successor about five months after Kim
Jong Il's near fatal stroke in 2008
after which she had trouble moving the
left side of his body
almost nothing was known about the then
roughly 25 year old dictator and waiting
who like his father slowly ascended the
party until December 17 2011 when Kim
jong-il also like his father died of a
heart attack
both times Outsiders watched the
transition first from a militant
revolutionary ideologue to an awkward
film nerd then to a basketball loving 28
year old with about three years of
experience and waited for the regime to
collapse each time they said the country
could not survive without the
personality behind the cult and each
time the transition was incredibly
smooth and there ten years long at some
point one must accept that for all their
villainous behavior the Kim family is
also extremely skilled strategically it
should come as no surprise then that as
of now there is no obvious next in line
which could present a serious threat to
the current leadership if tradition
continues as it tends to in North Korea
power will be inherited by one of Kim
Jong Un's male children two factors
however complicate this first of his
three reported children the oldest is
said to be only ten which let's hope is
far too young even by North Korean
standards second Kim Jong Un's physical
health is probably much worse than his
predecessors meaning there's a very real
chance he could die before any of his
children reach maturity which brings us
back to the family tree anyone with Kim
family blood according to the country's
culture and tradition is a potential
rival as evidenced by the assassination
of Kim jong-nam in 2017 while returning
to his home in Macau the eldest brother
was attacked and killed at a check-in
counter at Kuala Lumpur Airport carrying
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
cash he's suspected of being a CIA
informant and as evidenced by his 12
vials of antidotes a nervous one his son
Kim Han Seoul is currently in hiding and
would probably be extremely wise to
remain that way the most realistic
replacements however come from within
the country the most high-profile of
which is Kim jong-un sister kim yo-jong
when she first appeared in public at her
father's funeral so little was known
about her that some suspected she was
Kim Jong Un's wife since then she has
assumed the very public role of
essentially her brother's assistant she
can be seen standing behind him at
important meetings and handing him a pen
at signings many would recognize her
face from the 2018 Winter Olympics where
she made waves for standing during the
South Korean national anthem cheering
for the unified Korea flag and inviting
the president to meet with her brother
on one hand at the amount of power she
has accumulated and her physical
proximity to kim jong hoon is a clear
sign of trust but given that hoon had
his own uncle executed by firing squad
what looks like trust could just as
easily be doubt in her ability to pose a
threat while she does have the
all-important Kim family blood she would
likely struggle to gain support in the
North's very patriarchal culture making
her a valuable asset to the current
leadership her supposed father-in-law
the well-connected Cho Rong hae is
another possible contender as a member
of the party Standing Committee Central
Committee military commission and a
deputy of the Supreme People's Assembly
wrong hae is one of the most powerful
senior officials in the country although
he lacks the family blood and therefore
also the financial access he's had
decades to build and maintain a
coalition which could in theory
eventually be used to seize control that
leaves only kim gyeong-cheol the older
full brother of kim jong hoon Cheol
reportedly can be found in one of two
places in pyongyang where he plays
guitar or wherever eric clapton is
playing a concert
it would seem his father was right he
has no political ambitions or like all
of this so it's thought the trouble with
understanding North Korea is that so
much of what we know is based on stories
told by a select few insiders living
abroad people like Kenji Fujimoto
formerly the Kim family sushi chef who
watched Kim jong-un and his siblings
grow up with so little information on
which to go on few opportunities to
calibrate our understanding and North
Korea itself usually disinterested in
confirming or to
rumors the outside world faces a tough
dilemma it would be foolish to totally
disregard the few tidbits of information
we do have as unproven speculation but
it would also be foolish to accept them
wholeheartedly and risk being misled as
we saw happen with the recent reports of
Kim Jong Un's death the next time Kim
jong-eun disappears we may learn from
this mistake and quickly dismissed the
story and yet when he does eventually
disappear from the world for good that's
exactly how it will probably look when
Kim jong-il died in December 2011 the
world continued operating as usual
totally oblivious for 51 hours during
that time the South Korean president
flew to Tokyo met the Prime Minister and
flew back its defense minister was in a
meeting when the announcement was
finally made afterward the Obama
administration reluctantly admitted they
were quote largely bystanders as the
guard changed in this notoriously cruel
nuclear-armed nation as it turned out we
got lucky there was no chaotic struggle
for power and 25 million citizens didn't
come flooding through the Chinese border
next time no one knows for sure if like
me you're not busy managing the
succession of your dictatorship I'm
willing to bet you might have a little
extra time at the moment if you're going
to be stuck indoors why not make use of
that time to learn something new on
brilliant maybe you've always wanted to
learn programming brilliant has courses
to walk you through the very basics all
the way up to the high-level topics like
machine learning in quantum computing or
perhaps you're a science person in which
case you'll love its courses on topics
like gravitational physics and astronomy
or maybe you want the concepts in your
math homework explained in a way that
actually makes sense not just making you
memorize formulas brilliant has it all
on top of that brilliant gives you a new
puzzle or problem to solve every day on
it's beautifully made mobile app and
website where you can also ask questions
discuss solutions and dive deeper into
whatever topic interests you most start
learning today for free with the link in
the description the first 200 people
will also get 20% off the annual premium
subscription